Now let's make sure that this program has all
the properties we want. Namely, concurrency, absence of deadlock, and
mutual exclusion of the important shared memory. Does it
have concurrency? For this, we just need to convince ourselves
that the critical sections of the code are short.
This critical section here is just decrementing a variable and
sending a signal. Not much work to be done there.
And the tracker does the analogous thing. So we're okay
on that front. The top two blocks, just this one
and this one, these just check the condition and then
call the wait procedure. And then they immediately unlock afterwards.
So this also is short. Okay, so let's check off
concurrency. The absence of deadlock, we can convince ourselves that
both threads are never blocked. We can see that the
mutex_lock can't be responsible for a deadlock because both the
producer and consumer give up the lock writing after acquiring
it, just as we argued about concurrency. There
isn't much work to be done here. Nor is
there much going on up here. It's just a
matter of checking the value of the bufavail variable.
That leaves the possibility that we get blocked
on one of these cond wait calls. Let's suppose
that a digitizer is blocked on this line. Because
he's waiting for bufavail to be greater than zero.
Let's suppose that the digitiser is blocked because
he's waiting for a signal saying that bufavail is
greater than zero. We know that right after condwait
was called bufavail was zero. Remember we had the
lock at the time. This means that the tracker
can't possibly be blocked on its wait because that
would imply that bufavail were equal to max. We
also know that our digitizer unlocks the newtext variable.
Again, that's part of the cond wait call.
Hence, our tracker can't be blocked on this while
he tries to acquire the lock either. Eventually,
the tracker will get around to incrementing bufavail and
then sending the signal back to the digitizer
thread. And so we can be confident that eventually,
this signal will arrive and we'll exit this procedure.
The argument is analogous if we suppose that the
tracker is waiting on cond wait. That means
the digitizer will be able to make progress and
eventually decrement bufavail and send the signal. Alright, so
hopefully we've convinced ourselves that there's no deadlock. Lastly,
we want to convince ourselves, that we have achieved
mutual exclusion of the necessary shared memory. Well, the
use of this mutex box, around all the, accesses
and rights to bufavail should convince ourselves that we
don't have a race there. That leaves the frame
buff variable. But the logic of the program, that is
the logic of the ring buffer that we talked about
earlier, prevents the head from ever catching up with the
tail, or vice versa, as they chase each other
around the ring buffer. In fact that's the whole point
of the buff avail variable. So mutual exclusion is achieved,
and our program has all three properties that we desired.